in the summer of 2014
i found myself sitting across from a man
who by every definition was my enemy
his name was craig watts and he's a
chicken factory farmer
my career is devoted to protecting
farmed animals and
ending factory farming and up until this
point in my life
i had spent every waking moment
standing up against everything this man
stood for and now
i was in his living room the day i met
craig watts
he had been raising chickens for 22
years for a company called purdue
the fourth largest chicken company in
the entire country
and as a young man he had yearned for
this way
to stay on the land in one of the
poorest counties
in the state so when the chicken
industry came to town he thought
this is a dream come true he took a
quarter of a million dollar loan out and
he built these chicken houses
purdue would give him a flock he'd raise
them and each flock he'd get paid and
then he'd pay off in small increments
that loan like a mortgage
but pretty soon the chickens got sick
it's a factory farm after all there are
25 000
chickens that are stuffed wall to wall
living on their own feces
breathing ammonia-laden air and when
chickens get sick
some of them die and you don't get paid
for dead chickens and
craig started to struggle to pay off his
loan he realized he made a mistake
but he was all but an indentured servant
at this stage when i
met him he was at a breaking point
the payment seemed never ending as did
the death
despair an illness of his chickens
now if we humans tried to think of some
super unjust unfair
filthy and cruel food system we could
not have
thought of anything worse than factory
farming 80
billion farmed animals around the world
annually
are raised and slaughtered they're
stuffed in cages and warehouses never to
see the light of day
and that's not just a problem for those
farmed animals
animal agriculture it accounts for more
greenhouse gas emissions
than all of the planes trains and
automobiles put together
and one third of our arable land is used
to grow feed to feed factory farmed
animals rather than ourselves
and all that land is sprayed with
immeasurable chemicals
and ecologically important habitats
like the amazon are cut down
and are burnt all so we can feed and
house farmed animals
by the time my three kids grow up
there's very unlikely to be polar bears
sumatran elephants
orangutans in my lifetime
the number of birds amphibians reptiles
and mammals has
halved and the main culprit
is our global appetite for meat dairy
and eggs
and for me up until this point the
villain
was craig watts and as i sat there in
his living room
my fear and my anger turned into
something else
shame my whole life i had spent
blaming him hating him i even wished him
ill i had never once
thought about his struggle his choices
could he be a potential ally i never had
thought
he feels as trapped as the chickens
so we had been sitting there for hours
and
the midday turned into afternoon turned
into dust turned into darkness and he
suddenly said
okay are you ready to see the chickens
so under the cover of darkness
we walked towards one of these long gray
houses
and he swung open the door and we
stepped inside and we were hit with this
overpowering smell and every muscle in
my body tensed up and i coughed and my
eyes teared
i was too overwhelmed by my own physical
discomfort
i didn't even look around at first but
when i did what i saw
brought me to tears tens of thousands of
newly hatched chicks
in this darkened warehouse
with nowhere to go and nothing to do
over the next few months i returned many
times
with filmmaker reagan hodge to record to
understand to build trust with craig
and i walked his houses with him as he
picked up dead and dying birds
birds with messed up legs and trouble
breathing and
difficulty walking and all of this we
caught on film
and then we decided to do something i
don't think either he or i ever expected
to do when we first met we decided to
release that footage
and that was really risky for both of us
it was risky for him because he could
lose his income his home
his land his neighbors hating him and
i could risk getting my organization
sued or being the reason
that he would lose everything but we had
to do it anyway
the new york times broke the story and
in with 20
within 24 hours a million people had
seen
our video it went viral by every
definition and suddenly we had
this global platform for talking about
factory farming
and working with craig got me thinking
what other unlikely allies are out there
what other progress what other lessons
can i learn
if i cross those enemy lines
the first lesson i learned is that we
have to become
comfortable with being uncomfortable
only talking to people who agree with us
it's not going to get us to the solution
we have to be willing to enter other
people's space
because quite often the enemy has
the power to change the problem that
we're trying to solve in my case
i'm not in charge of a single chicken
the farmer is and so are the meat
companies so i need to enter their space
if i want to solve the problem
and a couple years after working with
craig i did something again i never
expected to do
i sat down with an even bigger so-called
enemy
jim perdue himself the man i had made
the villain of my viral video
and again through difficult
conversations and
being uncomfortable purdue came out with
the first
animal care policy of any poultry
company
and they agreed to do some of the things
we had criticized them for not doing in
the viral video like put windows
into houses and pay for them
and that was a really important lesson
for me
the second lesson is that when we
sit down to negotiate with the enemy
we need to remember there's a human
being in front of us that
very likely has more in common with us
than we care to admit
and i learned this firsthand when i was
invited to visit
at a major poultry company's
headquarters and it was the first time
that my organization had been invited in
and any organization had been invited
to visit with them and as we walked
through the corridor there were
literally people who were peeking out
from the cubicles to get a
quick look at what does an animal rights
activist look like and we walked
i look like this so i don't know what
they're expecting
but as we walked into the boardroom
there was an executive who was in charge
sitting there
and his arms were crossed and he did not
want me to be there
and i flipped open my laptop and my
background photo
came up and it was a picture of my three
kids
my daughter clearly looks different than
my son's
and when he saw that photo he uncrossed
his arms and he
tilted his head and he leaned forward
and he said are those your kids
and i said yeah i just got back from
adopting my daughter and i babbled
on way too much for a professional
meeting and
he stopped me and he said i have two
adopted kids
and for the next 20 minutes
we just talked about that we talked
about adoption and being a parents and
in those moments we forgot who we were
supposed to be at that table
and this the walls came down and a
bridge was built and we crossed this
divide
and more progress was made with that
company
because of that human connection that we
made
my last lesson for you is that
when we sit down with the so-called
enemy we need to look for the win-win
instead of going in with farmers like
craig watts and thinking i need to put
them out of farming
i started to think how can i help them
be different kinds of farmers like
growing hemp or mushrooms and a farmer i
later
worked with did exactly that
he did do the expose with me and filmed
and we went with the new york times
again
but he went beyond that he quit chicken
factory farming
and it turns out that those big long
gray warehouses
are the perfect environment for growing
something else
that's hemp people that's hemp
here's an environmentally friendly way
to stay on the land
to pay the bills that a vegan animal
rights activist
and a chicken farmer can get behind
and instead of thinking how can i get
these big meat companies out of business
i started thinking how can i help them
evolve into a different kind of business
one where the protein doesn't come from
slaughtered animals but rather
plants and believe it or not these big
companies are starting to move their
ships in that direction
cargill and tyson and purdue
are adding plant-based proteins into
their supply chain
and purdue himself said that
our company is a premium protein company
and nothing about that says that it has
to come from
animals and in my own hometown
of atlanta kfc did a one-day trial with
beyond
meat for plant-based chicken nuggets
and it was insane there were lines
wrapped around the corner there was
traffic stopped in all directions you
would think they were giving out free
beyonce tickets
people are ready for this shift
we need to build a big tent that
everyone can get under
from the chicken factory farmer to the
mega meat company
to the animal rights activist and
these lessons they can apply to many
causes whether
it be with a problem with an ex
a neighbor or an in-law
or with some of the biggest problems of
exploitation
and oppression like factory farming
or misogyny or racism or climate change
the world's smallest and biggest
problems
they won't be solved by beating down our
enemies but by
finding these win-win pathways together
it does require us to let go
of that idea of us versus them
and realize there's only one us
all of us against an unjust system
and it is difficult and messy and
uncomfortable
but it is critical and maybe
the only way to build that compassionate
food system
that we all from the chicken to the
chicken farmer
to the mega meat company to all of us
deserve thank you